thank you for talking to me about the
show i love the show on
two levels the whole nostalgia factor
from reading the books when i was
younger and how it also proves the good
stories and good character as a
universal universal no matter what your
agents
so what has it meant to you guys to get
to be a part of the babysitter's club
what's the coolest thing about being a
part of this world and doing this show
yeah i mean like you mentioned i think
it brings so much like nostalgia to
like all the um
individuals who have read the books
before and it also kind of introduces
introduces the books to like
uh and the stories of the babysitters to
a new generation as well and i also
think it's so great how like inclusive
and like diverse
um
this just the babysitter's club is in
general and how we get to see the
stories of
all these girls and how they handle each
of their problems because i think it's
so real and um
others watching can all relate to it
mo hit so many good points but i'll just
add that
these stories are really classic and
incredible and these characters are so
lovable and it's amazing just to be able
to bring them to life again for a new
generation also like you had said it's
just it's such an honor i feel very
lucky
you were pretty much able to make this
first season in your own little bubble
while the fans of the books didn't
really know what to expect but now with
the second season there's a certain
level of expectation
so did you guys feel an added sense of
pressure and responsibility to live up
to that or were you just excited about
getting to dive in even deeper
um i've been just excited and also like
um in season one we couldn't talk about
it at all because
the complete surprise we only announced
it once we'd already finished filming so
this time around it was really nice to
be able to
post when we were hanging out out of
filming um and just be able to say that
we were all together because um it's
it's definitely freeing when you're able
to do that so that was that was a nice
thing about season two but i i
personally didn't feel very much added
pressure i was just excited to play
stacy again
yeah i mean i'd have to agree i was just
just so excited to see the girls be back
with them for another season
um i think i really hope everyone will
love the second season because we
definitely had such a fun time filming
it so i really hope that that kind of
you know translates to
this the show
it does it's a great season
great i'm glad
you guys got to reunite to shoot the
second season but you've also added
mallory and jesse to the club and you
have kendra joining he's gone what was
it like to return to something familiar
but then also get to shake things up a
little bit
it's incredible um i think stacy has
this mindset which i have as well the
more the merrier and it's it's always
great to have new people join the club
and
i i can speak for both of us because i
know this is true we love them so much
and and they love us it's just this like
whole big group of friendship and it's
it's always amazing to have more people
added into that
yeah i'd have to agree
how nervous were you guys on your very
first day of playing your character and
did you have a moment when you felt like
things really clicked and you really got
them
yeah i mean i think like because these
characters were already like established
to so many people there was definitely a
little bit of pressure for sure and i
think all of us felt that but
it was really like once we filmed like
our first scenes scene together in
claudia's room is when i remember really
feeling connected to her and also just
seeing like what the what the audience
had to say
definitely gave me a lot more confidence
and like my portrayal of claudia and how
i understand her so i feel like i was
able to have a lot more fun with her
this season for sure
i think we all helped each other through
any nerves that we had and and i can say
that that's lasted through
until even just today like
being nervous about an interview we all
help each other through through all of
those things because we're going through
it at the exact same time so i think
being together and being with people
that we love definitely helped with that
but um
yeah just as soon as we started filming
it felt like home to me and being
being stacey felt like home so it was
incredible just to be able to finally
bring it to life rather than just being
in an audition room
what do you guys most love about your
character and what quality of theirs do
you wish you had for yourself
um well i really admire stacy's
confidence and i think she's also a very
responsible hard-working girl so i think
those are incredible traits that she
holds amongst many others but um i
strive to be as confident as she is
yeah i think for claudia she's just so
like unapologetically her own self and
she really doesn't care about what
others have to say about her as much
and that's something that i admire and i
try to you know incorporate i guess into
my own
like when it comes to my own
self-confidence as well
momona claudia becomes closer with her
sister this season and we get to learn a
little bit more about their relationship
together
what did you enjoy about that dynamic
and getting to see how different the two
of them are but how they still can
really love each other
yeah i mean i think the first season
dived into that a little bit but this
season we were really able to see
um an even stronger connection between
the two sisters and um i think
uh sorry i lost my my channel hold on
yeah i think even though they're just
they're so different they learn to
really love each other for their own
qualities and you know i think claudia
really admires janine in ways that maybe
she can exactly like say right to her
but i think there's this one really
beautiful moment when she tells janine
that it's like no matter what like she's
there for her and i think that was
really great
she i also really love that we get to
see the role that diabetes plays in
stacy's life it's something she just has
to learn to live with and figure out how
to balance so what does it mean to you
to be telling this story and what do you
hope other young people get from
watching how she handles it
it is such an honor to be able to
portray stacy who is such an iconic
character and such a
incredible representation of people who
have type 1 diabetes and and young girls
who are dealing with that so
um aside from that i think it's just a
very real thing to be coming to terms
with something about yourself that you
can't change and you can't control and
you have to just learn to love and i
think stacy does a really good job of
doing exactly that and i hope people can
see her on screen just
fully taking charge and and not
apologizing for who she is and they can
learn to do that in their own lives as
well
do you guys have your own personal wish
list for your character and things you
still want to learn about them or get to
do or explore with them in the future
no
yeah that's a good question i think
uh
just
continuing and like watching how they
they transition into
their later teen years if if we do get
the opportunity to do more um i think
that would be interesting because you
know as they grow up and grow older
there's going to be new
uh challenges that each of the
characters face and i will
would love to see kind of
uh how the
events of this season could affect um
claudia in the later seasons if if we
get a chance to do more
um yeah i think just seeing the
friendships continue to evolve because i
know they have from the beginning of
season one to the end of season two
they've grown so much in real life and
on screen so i think it it's just always
incredible to see those evolve and to
see our our group of girls get even
tighter together and i think also with
stacy she
goes through many things internal
struggles and also uh figuring out her
relationships with other people whether
it be french foreign
there's a lot of good things to work
with
what if you guys learned about
yourselves as actors from doing the show
has being a part of this taught you
anything about what it takes to do
something like this or working with such
a diverse group of other actors
um i think it's shown me how much i love
it and how much i want to do this for as
long as possible um
it takes a lot of hard work and
dedication to be
filming every single day but i know that
having such an amazing cast to work with
definitely makes it easier makes it feel
less like work and more fun but it's
really proven to me that this is what i
want to do with my life
yeah i'd have to completely agree just
being able to observe and watch the
other girls work has definitely just
taught me a lot within itself like
i think that has been one of the biggest
lessons as well as you know like
understanding that if i if like this is
like shay said this is exactly kind of
what i want to do and this is really
like one of the only things i can see
myself doing at the moment
and
yeah i just hope that all of our hard
work pays off with this season for sure
well thank you guys so much you are so
perfect for these characters i
appreciate you talking to me
thank you